good morning everyone so I would like to
start on time so it's 10:15 I know that
some of you are getting in I will just
spend a couple of minutes and then hand
it over to our first speaker so welcome
to the session on micro productivity
it's a nice continuation from the two
keynotes that we attended because there
Jamie and Gloria were talking about
focus and attention and the challenges
that we have in maintaining focus to get
things done and in this session we're
going to talk about alternative ways of
actually getting things done where you
may not have to focus for longer periods
of time I am John Sewall I am going to
be chairing this session we have four
amazing speakers who will take us
through their research on micro
productivity we have Lydia Chilton from
Columbia University
Steven Dell from UCSD Walter lisicki
from University of Michigan and Victor
posnansky from Microsoft experiences and
devices division so I'm gonna start off
to just ice break a little bit so how
many people in this room have a laptop
or a smartphone with them okay almost
everyone I mean if you don't have one
you might stand out how many people have
been using it during the keynotes as I'm
speaking to maybe check your email you
think that this is going to be super
boring introduction so I might as well
just get all my emails out of the way so
that is smart maybe to just quickly chat
with someone post something on social
media yeah so I'm pretty certain that
people have been doing that and the
reason why I bring this up is not
because I want to call you out I want to
point to the fact that we are all doing
this because we care about efficiency
we're trying to make the most of the
time that we have available so very
briefly speaking microtasks our
perceptual perceptual units of behavior
that are basically things that belong to
larger tasks and these smaller tests you
can do in a very small micro-moments the
notion of micro productivity is
basically doing a series of
these micro tasks that require very
little context and eventually contribute
towards a larger goal so the idea is
that you could still get things done
without having to set aside longer
periods of time to do it the reason why
micro productivity and micro tasks work
in the current scenario is because we
have days full of micro moments our
attention is fragmented we are on the go
a lot of time we have devices that allow
us to do a lot of things and we are
actually able to take advantage of these
things okay so as I said I wouldn't take
too much time and so this is the list of
our presenters and the way that this is
going to work is that our presenters
will give about a 10 minute or so
presentation on topics on micro
productivity that they're working on and
then we will have an open discussion
with all the presenters up on the in
front and that's where we will hopefully
go away with a lot of fun research ideas
to move this field forward so without
further ado I'm going to introduce Lydia
children who is a assistant professor at
Columbia University do I get a clicker
for slides
[Music]
so you can't use these micro elements
should we try it boom that's me okay
great yes so I'm going to talk about
micro tasks to augment our fluid
intelligence something really key to
solving problems but I'm first gonna
tell you about this very cool little
problem called creating visual blends
these are images that convey a message
symbolically this is the cover of The
Economist a news article trying to
convey that Brazil is taking off with a
symbol of Brazil with a symbol of
something else that takes off this is an
advertisement for Tabasco conveying that
it's hot like a fire extinguisher and
this is a public service announcement
without words anyone guess what this
means anyone willing to shout it out yes
global warming that the earth is melting
right so this is really useful news
advertisements public service
announcements and not always as useful
this is actually considered one of those
creative tasks in fact if you search for
creative ads these are largely the kinds
of things that come up so the first one
is trying to indicate that McDonald's
has Wi-Fi that Red Bull has energy
skipping the alcohol ones and that
smoking kills I'm actually curious about
if you guys see this one Oh
what's in that image it shoes and lungs
now many people hate this one they can't
see it at all it is is terrible
they're all subjective some people will
get them some people will not that's
sort of part of the charm is that if you
don't get it you might say something to
someone and they can explain it to you
and then you've started a conversation
anyway but all of these are examples of
visual blends and I want to support
people in creating them so we want to
break this problem into tasks well it's
a creative problem so it's gonna be hard
and there's no simple pattern for they
all have different colors different
objects different meanings so how are we
gonna find a pattern well the clue here
is that we want to that they all share a
shape that they blend together so for
the pub
service announcement about global
warming the earth is a sphere the ice
cream has a sphere and that allows you
to blend them so that you can see them
both they're both integrated and they're
both individually identifiable we need
to show you an example of that mouse so
this is a quick mock-up of it happening
so the Tabasco bottle is a pretty
complicated shape but at a high level
it's a cylinder which in 2d is a
rectangle so that's about what its shape
is and the fire extinguisher is an even
more complicated shape but its body its
main element is also a cylinder so you
can see how these two things would go
together it's as on maybe that doesn't
quite look right and now we have a
pretty good first pass at that blend
here's one more example this is a public
service announcements for turn off and
your cell phone so the symbol of turn
off is a light in the off switch and
that's a rectangle so great the phone is
also a rectangle so at first blush this
looks pretty great but there's going to
be a problem that if you mask out the
entire phone you will not be able to see
it so instead we want an internal part
of the phone that leaves enough of it
visible so you can identify it so
masking that a little bit more carefully
that is the finished product
public service announcement so that is
the design pattern and we can use this
create this design pattern to turn this
into a search problem we want to search
for symbols of Earth and symbols of melt
that both have this circle or this
shared shape in common so I'll just take
you through a quick example of what the
micro tasks are in this workflow for
Starbucks in summer okay so first you
brainstorm what you associate with
Starbucks store Frappuccino green straws
that sort of stuff then turn that into
simple iconic objects like the logo like
blue the normal Frappuccino and figure
out what shape they are circles that a
cylinder isn't at all the object or part
of the object do the same thing for
summer independently beach Sun swim some
nice images you know their shapes
they're part of it now they've got this
big database
and we can computationally solve this
constraint of finding out two objects
that share the same shape but one has
bits outside the shape that identify it
so a computer can automatically create a
mock-up and a person can come through
and say is this basically on the right
track but there's a way we can improve
this without changing the shapes but I
thinking about the secondary visual
features like color textures I don't
have an idea of what would make this
better more blended sometimes people can
Intuit it this is what our our users
came up with is if you turn the
Starbucks yellow it's still identifiable
but it's more blended with the Sun so
this is the output of the system if you
didn't find things you could continue to
iterate but that's those are the micro
tasks that are needed to do this process
and it's a combination of people and
computers there's an interface to do
this where each of the stages are in
sort of their own vertical with a
computational stage in between it'll
output lots and lots of images and
people can choose the best ones to
continue to iterate on Joe's coffee is a
local coffee shop at Columbia campus and
a student group made a blend for them
being opened late at night they found
this another was football being
dangerous as a public service
announcement and they came up with this
hand-washing is smart there's many ways
to represent smart the volumetric flask
is one of them and the philosophy
departments Christmas party they came up
with this which I did not understand the
philosophy students were in this and
they tell me that it is some classic
problem that all freshmen argue about in
dorm rooms until 2:00 in the morning
blended with Christmas okay so these are
visual blends are made by groups of
people trying to do it for their own
tasks we've also done a study on this
with novices with without the system
showing that they're 10 times better
with the system even a time frame they
can make more either when they have it
first or second so 10x improvements is
pretty good on this so why why is this
helping people well
here's some case studies users fertile
for combining bicycle and smart came up
with this which isn't such a great blend
and it has this sort of a plus thrown on
the top of the bike in a kind of weird
way what happens is novices get stuck
improving their first idea by adding
more things but instead
invisablend it helps them have many
ideas to pick the best one another case
is for New York City and night so users
unassisted came up with this which is
okay the moon's a good symbol of night
and the skylines a good example of New
York but although they picked these
perfect symbols the shape fit just isn't
there but with visible ends there was
more shapes and novices could meet all
the strengths especially the harder ones
like the shape fit by finding slightly
less iconic symbols but being able to
meet the overall shape fit so we
decompose these blends into microtasks
ten times improvement but the real
question is why is this helping what
when and what generalizable principle
could we come up with here to do solving
real hard creative problems with
microtasks so I want to show you the
process for football is dangerous first
we found this helmet and it would
through a bunch of examples and come up
with this blend which is okay but it
could be better
so to refine this they did a new search
for football helmet and white came up
and mocked these examples and they
picked this example out of this
combination out of all of them because
it had these better secondary fits but
in general what's being supported here
through the design process is separating
the crystallized intelligence from fluid
intelligence so crystallized
intelligence is like having the
resources and the tools and these
memorized procedures right at your
fingertips like a painter has your fluid
intelligence is then putting that all
together in real time and if you don't
have to pause your painting to go mix up
a new color you can do a lot better and
that's exactly what we're doing with
this system that's how we rod menteng
fluid intelligence because we collect
the resources and then
combine them and then to iterate collect
new resources and combine them so we
have Crystal fluid crystal and fluid
intelligence steps so just to summarize
we got this improvement because micro
tests and computation can set the stage
but for fluid intelligence we're working
on all sorts of other problems of
merging two fields or two discipline two
disciplines together by searching
through things finding combinations of
having all the resources at your
fingertips to prototype them as Steven
is setting up I initially thought that
we won't do questions but I felt that
rather than allowing you to use your
microphones and I will keep coming back
to this joke so it will get all pretty
soon so if you have if one question for
Lydia we can quickly do one question I
will hand you over to Mike thanks it was
really interesting see him see all that
I want to ask about I guess was those
the micro micro tasks he went through
did people come to understand them as
steps in themselves I did people start
to see that as like a move that's an
important move to make during that
process well like were they able to kind
of deconstruct them into those tasks
themselves do people start to see in
that way or did they see it as part of a
bigger process and we've run it in
several different ways and we teach them
both what the individual pieces are and
how they go together the pieces without
having how they go together ends in
nothing good you get a bunch of images
of stuff and they they don't fit so they
they are part and parcel is this like
you have a bunch of paint but never
paint a painting that would be weird
you need some notion of what your
ultimate goal is to pick the colors I
don't know what else you do in painting
I only watch the show I don't actually
thank you great question all right I'll
hand it over
so I just go i I am NOT doing my
responsibilities as well so let's
welcome Steven Dow who is from UCSD and
Steven is going to be talking about
helping communities design together
through my micro-volunteering thank you
so I'm very honored to be here speaking
about the future of work an area of
growing importance and over the past
decade or so my group has really focused
on the intersection of creative work and
crowdsourcing really thinking about what
what sort of comes out of that space
with the goal of really helping people
design together to address complex
problems and recently my group has been
studying this kind of setting groups of
people gathered together in a public
setting to design solutions for their
community and through these observations
we have come to believe that design
really offers a wonderful empathetic
human centered way to look at problems
facing our world but that these design
methods are not enough society has
problems too vast complex and
interconnected for any one room of
people to solve we certainly can and
should educate people about data and
design methods and arm them with you
know modern problem-solving skills but
these methods alone are not enough a
single team no matter how diverse
hard-working talented thoughtful can
only explore a problem within their
capabilities and due to these limits on
time ability cost skills single teams
can only explore so many questions so
many framings of a problem so many
different alternative solutions so I
argue truly complex problems require
collective effort and not the kind of
collective effort where you just bring a
bunch of people together and they have
their devices and see what happens but
the kind where we carefully structure
how people interact through social
computing systems so as one example of
what my group has been working on we
created an online system called
community krit short for community
critique and the idea here is its
intended to supplement
and scale up the kinds of conversations
that happen in these public workshops
and our tool borrows ideas from
crowdsourcing where we try to gather
meaningful micro contributions in a
short amount of time
this micro-volunteering model recognizes
that people want to have a voice but
often don't have a lot of time it's part
of the reason why the whole city doesn't
show up to the to the public workshop
people simply don't have the time to
attend these things a lot of times so
through the tool the participants can
learn about a civic proposal and then
they're led through a series of micro
volunteering tasks where they might
elaborate the proposal they might
critique the proposal along a certain
rubric they might rate a concept on
different dimensions so as one instance
of this workflow one community member
might create a proposal for a tower as
part of an urban development effort they
may even sketch it and upload it during
the public workshop and then a second
community member would come along and do
a set of activities around that proposal
so we had several can duck tivities but
in this case the participant might be
asked to pose a question for another
community member and in that case a
third community member would come along
to answer that question and what this
does is it gives us a nice rich layered
dataset and in the end people from the
local neighborhood submitted a bunch of
proposals and we got a bunch of rich
qualitative feedback on each proposal so
our deployment gave us some indication
that the participants appreciated this
approach it gave them an opportunity to
express their voice and they also
contrasted it with some other data
gathering techniques like surveys which
tended to be lengthy and and feel like
it wasn't best tapping into their to
their abilities in that moment urban
planners also liked the fact that it
gave their community a chance to express
their ideas and they talked about how
those perspectives can be brought back
into the workshops to help frame how the
broader community is thinking about the
problem however
some planners express skepticism one set
of gave voice to people too lazy to get
off their couch and come to the
workshops which shows that some planners
still view face-to-face meetings as the
place where design can happen
nonetheless we demonstrated that this
approach around community crit provides
a structured approach to enabling a
large community to constructively
elaborate and discuss design proposals
and that's just one example of my
group's research on helping communities
solve problems through this
micro-volunteering model to touch on a
few more examples we built prototypes to
facilitate conference planning where
organizers can gather input from an
academic community such as the author's
and the attendees before the conference
to help plan a better conference we
explore the idea of the classroom as a
cloud as a crowd you know the fact that
in most classrooms nowadays everyone has
a device you know in this room everyone
has a device so can we tap into that
those moments where the audience is
sitting there possibly to do things that
are constructive for presenters for
peers doing interactive learning
activities and that sort of thing we've
also experimented with how to leverage
online crowds to inspire idea generation
in sort of a studio environment but I
think what I'm most excited to explore
with these models of micro-volunteering
are these civic contexts public meetings
are still the status quo for addressing
civic issues but they're problematic for
a number of reasons they can often be
dominated by a few outspoken individuals
they are limited to those who can fit in
the physical room or have the time to
come and attend these events for
contentious issues people often don't
even listen to each other so my group
and I feel really compelled to rethink
public engagement in civics in 2017 we
started this initiative called design
for San Diego a citywide design
competition where people address a key
problem like transportation in this case
and all the many threads that come along
with a commuting parking accessibility
likeability preparing for autonomous
vehicles and one goal is to create an
educational experience for young people
there's nothing that young folks like
more than having an opportunity to learn
by doing on problems that can
potentially make a real impact and it
didn't hurt to have the San Diego mayor
the UCSD Chancellor and design guru Don
Norman there to kick off the event and
get people really excited about this
another goal was to partner with
organizations in the community to bring
together young innovators professional
designers domain experts key
decision-makers to potentially get some
of these ideas off the ground to really
ground this in the community and over
the course of several months hundreds of
people came out and participated in
different ways and submitted ideas solid
ideas like beach access for all a Center
for helping people get more comfortable
with the experience of writing and an ad
what's that human experience of giving
control over the car a system for
learning drivers about nearby bikes to
improve bike safety and the winning team
was not a group of professional
designers but a team of high school
students providing validation that
everyday people from the community can
have ideas and energy and optimism and
our goal here is to harness that and
coordinate that and now due to our
success in the in 2017 we're bringing it
back next year and not only will this
provide an awesome educational
experience in a way that connects with
the community but we're really working
to try to integrate our research on
social computing and the underlying
mechanisms behind this this idea of
getting people to collectively innovate
together and we have a bunch of
interesting research questions that our
group is exploring now like how can we
create roles for stakeholders it within
the Civic design process you're really
rethinking how Civic design can work how
can
we discover and model a problem space so
that we more equitably address the real
problems facing a community how can we
leverage solutions that other people
have already thought about in other
cities
and provide those as inspiration and
help get sense making around those
examples how can we motivate and
scaffold community members to provide
feedback you know thinking about the the
ways that these ideas improve and how do
we create more resilient and flexible
team structures that work in these
ecosystems where people often have a
wide range of skills motivations and
levels of commitment so this is very
much a work in progress but here's the
basic structure we envision for this
next year we're gonna have a series of
in-person events so much like the the
public workshops that will start off
with discussions fireside chats really
to kick off a discourse around the
problems that a city faces or a
community faces and then it will go on
to these design and prototyping
workshops what we call design a Thon's
getting lots of people together in a
setting to to generate ideas and then
finally a large summit where people have
come back with some information about
their ideas some feedback about their
ideas and they pitch their ideas and and
hopefully that becomes a great
opportunity for the community to share
and support different proposals and
we'll scaffold activities throughout
this initiative so the in-person events
will be structured and facilitated
around particular activities there'll be
homework that these participants do
between the activities to really connect
it and we do see these young energized
innovators sort of the center of this
ecosystem but we envision micro micro
volunteering type roles for experts
mentors feedback providers judges we
hope that this builds momentum
throughout the year so that we have the
right people in the room when it comes
to the summit and hopefully help us gain
traction on some of these these great
proposals and I think that's where it
connects back
into this idea of future of work and
micro productivity is how do we take
micro you know micrometers about to
their community not to just to their own
productivity for their own tasks but
something that we can create as a whole
so that's the end of my ten minutes
thank you Thank You Steven for this
excellent overview of how micro scale
level individual contributions can
contribute towards larger community and
societal problems as Walter is sitting
in so I have again time for one question
so the person who has their hand up
first which is Andrew gets to ask it we
will have a larger discussion at the end
so please hold your questions if you
don't get a chance to present them now
thanks for the nice presentation so I
noticed that it all starts out with an
in-person meeting right and I'm curious
how you feel about starting out with
in-person meetings we're just starting
out with the micro engagements which are
online and perhaps how would that differ
yeah it's interesting I do think you
need the in-person events just as a
general role you can't you can't really
get the kind of rapport and the the
commitment unless you have people
together in the room that's just my
intuition about it but there's also this
kind of chicken and egg thing where you
have to advertise and get the word out
about the physical event so in
technically you actually start digitally
you start with emails and website and
traditional marketing method
approaches to get people there but then
the idea is hopefully we can capture
what happens at those meetings transfer
transfer some of that thought up to the
digital world create productive
opportunities for people to engage in
micro moments and then have that fuel
the whole process but if you have ways
that you can see improving this or if
you want to support us and/or help in
some way we love to talk to you so talk
more thanks Steven so whenever I have
talked about my own work in micro
productivity I always get the question
is that well who's going to create these
tasks so thankfully there are people who
are working on these parts of the
research and so Walter Lusaka from
University of Michigan is going to talk
about how we can break down tasks and
create these micro tasks he has a much
better title alright thanks for having
me here and I'm happy today to talk a
little bit about how we think more
broadly about task decomposition so I'm
gonna talk a little bit less about my
own work a little bit more generally
about tasking and why micro productivity
in particular is something that we
should be thinking about but of course
that means I'm gonna start with a quick
overview of my own work so my lab
focuses on how to create hybrid
intelligence systems so these are
systems that are either primarily
artificially intelligent systems or at
least intelligent in some way of
interaction and then we're gonna
scaffold these systems by adding back in
human intelligence we think about new
ways to coordinate groups especially in
real-time to accomplish tasks that maybe
no one individual could accomplish alone
we then think about how to take an
automated system that might partially be
able to complete that task and fill in
when that system fails especially in
machine learning systems so that you can
actually deploy things before they work
perfectly but even have people kind of
save the day which necessary and then
increasingly we're thinking about better
ways to use what people understand about
the world to Train automated systems
more quickly and more robustly than just
simple label data which is a lot of what
we've seen in the past so in doing a lot
of this work we think about new ways to
push work at all levels of engagement to
the to the boundaries can we get people
to meaningfully contribute to a complex
task in 30 seconds can we get people to
benefit from longer engagement but then
not have any assumptions about how long
they may choose to stay engaged with a
task and then how do we do that with
teams that may not just include people
alone
so crowdsourcing historically has
thought about how to divide work such
that each of the micro tasks coming out
don't need the same level of context so
you don't need to necessarily have an
understanding of what was going on
before or what the rest of the task
entails but you can get a small unit of
work and this this is actually a great
model for potentially achieving micro
productivity so you can now switch back
into something that you didn't need to a
page in a lot of information to
accomplish complete that task and move
on some variants on this like self
sourcing actually looks at working on
tasks yourself in the future so breaking
down tasks that you yourself can later
complete them and often this is in
contrast to role based work so instead
of hiring somebody for a given role or a
job that they will perform over time we
think of the the task itself as the unit
of operation and then we figure out how
to construct more complex workflows from
individual tasks my own research has
actually tried to break that model
bringing continuity back in but assuming
that we can avoid these assumptions by
having a highly breakable continuous
workflow so if I'm here for five minutes
if I'm here for twenty five minutes I
can benefit from the context that I
build up in that task and yet at the
same time the assistant makes no
assumptions about how long I actually
have to stay engaged as a worker so when
we talk about micro productivity the
goal here is not just to work all the
time right it doesn't mean that we need
to backfill every little two-second
downtime you have in your day with
productive effort it also doesn't mean
that we just want you to do more work
right and in fact the like you said you
could even be doing tasks that are not
necessarily work itself so the way I'm
gonna frame this is that our goal here
is to get more done at the right times
so if you want to be accomplishing a
task that was on your to-do list then go
ahead and and get it done and Jamie TVN
and others like in the self store is the
original self sourcing work I have
really nice examples of doing that both
for personal and professional tasks okay
but we often want to get more things
done so I'm gonna have a
running metaphor for how we think about
work that focuses on something else that
most people want more of whenever they
can get it chocolate and of course the
only problem with chocolate is that this
is not actually the size it's a
significantly smaller but if you think
about you know a single piece so you see
if you want a piece of chocolate that's
great this is well-defined unit this
little candy here it's feasible to
complete or eat and this might represent
a small well-defined task that we want
to complete but it is small and if I
only have this I'm not going to be
particularly efficient or productive
during my day so we can solve that this
is a picture of an actual chocolate bar
that you can buy on Amazon it's ten
pounds so certainly you solve the volume
problem here right you got plenty of
chocolate but this monolithic slab this
large volume of kind of undifferentiated
in this case chocolate or work it's a
little bit impractical to to eat or
complete at once
right so that's not exactly what we want
if we break it up into small pieces
somewhat haphazardly we end up with
these irregular bits that are hard to
plan over I don't know exactly what the
task size might be it's hard to to stop
eating a piece or you know have a
certain amount and then say I want to
move on to the next thing so you can
think about that is task resumption of
the keynotes both had touched on this
idea in tasking right we're these are
regular pieces are really hard to plan
over but the perks are that it's very
easy to do this division because we kind
of just let tasks break whenever either
we have to we get interrupted or when we
we feel like that's a good time for a
stop okay so can we do this better well
we could go back to this idea of
individual pieces of chocolate so
manufactured pieces and this works
really nicely because again we get the
manageable size and they're consistent
so this would be a lot of the work that
I just mentioned in crowdsourcing that
focuses
on designing ways to break down work
into small units but it is very high
cost right it takes a lot of upfront
energy to make sure that all of the
pieces of work that I have to accomplish
are in such a nice uniform units and it
might not always be true that I want
them to be uniform I might have some
more time or more focus or more energy
to put into a task at one point than I
do at another so I might want actually
the variability between different tasks
that I can take ok so overall and I kind
of have the the parallels in chocolate
and work here so what do we want we want
the ability to do a lot of things or at
least the ability not to block based on
what is currently known that we have to
accomplish I want to get my high-level
goals without having to worry about
exactly how many small pieces are all
ready to go
I want manageable units of work and I
want them to be somewhat predictable so
even if they're not completely uniform I
want to be able to predict how much work
I'm taking off the stack at one time and
that might vary based on context so I
can pick that size and then finally I
want to be very easy to create these
units and so let's take some inspiration
for what chocolate actually did which is
add gridlines
right we have intentionally designed
points at which you can break it's not
infinitely high resolution but there is
some quantization here you can pick one
little bot you know one little segment
or you can pick 2 or 3 or 4 depending on
what you want they're consistent you
know what you're gonna get and there's a
there's a nice clean break point where
you can easily and resume a task if you
choose to take break at that point so
this is nice but what I'm going to argue
and I think what's interesting going
forward is the idea that this requires
intentional design right we had to
design this chocolate bar like that we
have to design work in the same way such
that we have a plan for how people can
index in and find the units of work that
they want to complete at a given time
I have to give a lot of credit to Harman
who's lead PhD students on a lot of this
work with many collaborators from
Microsoft Research and and a lot of her
thesis is thinking about not only how to
do this for individual work but situated
in teams so it might not just be that I
get interrupted because there's some
external factor to my work but it might
be to complete my work I need to go talk
to another person on my team or to make
sure that my team is productive overall
I need to be able to help support others
who are doing a different task or at
least or a different point in that task
that I wasn't thinking about and he goes
back to a lot of the interruption and
tasking work that we saw and focus work
that we saw in the two keynotes so I'll
stop there
a nice simple summary here and look
forward to questions on the panel Thank
You Walter and if anyone has now
chocolate cravings I encourage you to
talk to Walter at the end of this
session so again as Victor is going to
make up we have time for one question
so the first hand up okay so I will ask
this question because this is something
that I mean so for complex tasks
something like say programming or I mean
writing I mean we have done a little bit
in that space but have you thought about
the eventual quality so if you're doing
things via micro tasks what would be the
quality or do you have any sense of
right so tasks like writing tend to be
highly interconnected right need to
remember all of the characters that I
have in the novel I have to be able to
thread that story together at the match
style over time etc etc and so I think
that the the model still works but the
question is where and how you deal with
dependencies and that's an incredibly
difficult problem that by and large we
don't know how to solve all of certainly
you know some of your work and others
has a nice job moving forward and
finding some paths I think also I saw
Michael Bernstein in the audience
somewhere another another one was great
working the space but we are gonna have
to come up with a set of tools that
allow us to deal with those dependencies
kind of cut them when possible but
maintain them when necessary that might
change the size of the different units
so you can imagine a not perfectly
uniform set of break points on a
chocolate bar Thanks
I'm sure we'll have more to talk about
when we have the discussion I slipped in
this slide because this will lead us
straight into the discussion so I'm
going to invite all the speakers to come
up on stage in the meantime if you have
a specific question from before Victor
we can start off there but we're going
to start our open discussion now if you
have questions there's someone in the
back with microphones who will run
around just raise your hand and we'll
make sure that we get to you
okay so yeah I came up with this initial
list because whenever we talk about
micro productivity there are all these
questions about I mean the first and
foremost is are you going to ruin my
free time so you're now making me work
on my phone and work outside of my
workplace and is that going to destroy
what we consider as free time if you
remember that keynote this morning from
Gloria taking breaks is important you
want to be able to take breaks and so
for the panelists this is my question is
that how do you deal with this notion of
using micro moments to get things done
and how does that interact with your
need to take break and stay away from
work okay it's me
all right so I have my own personal
strategy for this that is based on my
research I think of everything as
constraints and I actually got this from
the management literature that talks
about when you have a company you really
think what's our goal what's the number
one thing we want to be doing so you
don't get distracted by the little
implementation details so a lot of what
I do is writing so when you write a
document it's about that thesis
statement you need the supporting
arguments and all the data and blah blah
blah and those to do here those are all
over and I know I'm gonna use my
crystallized intelligence to go find
them later but for me it's a
back-and-forth process
I'll have the thesis I'll go find those
bits I'm like oh this data doesn't
actually support this thesis brainstorm
a couple more theses and everything is
always sort of in motion um very often
instead of using a word doctor right
I'll use PowerPoint because I love
moving the slides around and I love
having the images in there anyway so by
dividing my work up and took in straits
and thinking about what's the thesis
what's the evidence and using tools
where I can move them around I feel like
I can regain that state when I need to
and I can take a break once I feel like
okay here's an idea for what my thesis
should be I've done a little work into
it now it's stuck I'm gonna go away have
some lunch come back and rethink about
that pieces and we do know that
brakes are important because as Gloria
said 20 minutes of taking a walk can
make you more creative anyone else have
a thought on this I would add to that I
used my inbox as a to-do list I don't
know if you guys do that so I send
myself tasks emails to remind myself
when I'm doing email to do that thing I
tell other people send me an email to
remind me to do that thing I have 20,000
unread emails I would just drown it
doesn't work for everyone so everyone
has their own strategy clearly well I'll
get to it eventually well so I think
this idea of eating up your personal
time or your break time is often I think
overstated a little bit right you can be
efficient in taking a break as well
right when I'm waiting at a bus stop and
I want to just use that time to do
something productive that's because I
don't want to do that thing later when I
want to take a break and I want
consistency in taking a break in a lot
of cases just as much as I do when I'm
trying to focus on work so being able to
kind of I guess defrag a little time in
my day so that it's actually
constructive in the way that I want it
to be whether that be to recover or to
actually produce is something I think
more flexibility is generally good as
long as we can not get stuck in the
little baiting traps that Gloria talked
about like stealing your attention away
so Jamie had this thought a few years
ago and when she said that I want to
turn people's work weeks into 30 hour
work weeks and we want to be able to
save an hour a day I don't know whether
that adds up to 40 I think it does at 30
but yeah I think that that is one of the
motivations is that if you can get those
lingering thoughts out and done somehow
and then you actually free up more time
so I'm looking at the audience now if
anyone has any questions hi Julie
University of Michigan so unlike what
you are just talking about which is
doing micro tasks from your own work I'm
interested in micro tasks for someone
else's work so I guess that's more in
line with some of the stuff that you
were talking about Walter and I guess
the reason I bring this up is that Jamie
and her keynote she mentioned putting
like the personal growth forefront for
people who are doing these this type of
work and I guess I'm wondering what is
lost from just doing the micro tasks in
knowing that small bit versus knowing
the wider context so like let's say if
you're working on a big project and
you're just doing a small amount there's
something that's beneficial from knowing
that whole context for a year like your
career or learning these skills so what
do you think is lost and is that a
problem or how can you support that
greater context without losing the
benefits of the micro part of it yeah so
by default yeah no I think that's a good
point right there are these little
learning benefits and they're all these
chances to accrue context that is useful
later so in answering Chauncey's
question after my talk right this idea
of dependencies that are formed between
different pieces of information in the
task is going to be important if you can
pick those up along the way you get kind
of often on board or kind of ramp up to
a larger or a more productive period of
time I think that's something that we
also want to have an intention with the
design of workflows and systems to help
with that I think though it again fits
into this model right where if we're
thinking about that unit as having dual
benefits one it's getting completed but
also it can help you get on board into
another task maybe that means I pick
something slightly larger if I have a
moment longer because I know that one
isn't as contextual II relevant to the
rest of the things that you need to be
doing so you can start planning over
these different kind of chunks of work I
think one of the things that's also
important here is that right now I feel
that we're still in kind of the these
initial stages of how we can make the
most use of micro tasks and so one of
the things that we have been actively
thinking about is that in terms of when
people are doing micro tasks how much
context should B be sharing and it's
kind of like the context could be not
only the local context about the task
itself but where does it stand in terms
of the larger goal that you have
and we don't quite know yet I mean how
this should look like but that is one of
the things that we have been actively
thinking about so that's a super
relevant question for that I will tell
you so I've done to test that the visib
lens that I showed and also the
conference scheduling that that Stephan
talked about I've done to the version
where everyone's totally independent and
does not have that context an aversion
with all the cotton you have micro tasks
but you can also see the big picture the
only one that really works is when you
can see the big picture things just get
lost between those breaking points
unless you know what the overall goal is
it can fill in those details this always
felt intuitively true to me and I have
two data points on it so I'm going for
that and also just going and
particularly for the whole context thing
just going over it again and again is
there any other way to make something
good then just go over it a million
times that is the only way I've figured
it out there's this book called the
design of everyday things it has some
evidence for that yeah Steve you had
something - I was gonna I was gonna
point out the importance of yes yes you
have to explain how this fits in but
also kind of the model of the big global
picture of how this is being done I
think it's both an answer to how do you
motivate people and and help them
contextualize the work that they're
doing but also it's really important for
how do we even do this in the first
place and I think it's kind of an answer
to the third question up there how do we
actually convert complex tasks into
micro type of work you have to have a
theory or a model or a framework for how
that micro work is being done and we've
seen it here we saw a very very broken
down model of how to make these ads we
saw you know I think we're just starting
to learn about what Civic design means
and how to really think about how you
know policies and proposals and change
happens in a city we saw it in some of
the other work we we've heard about is
you have to start with like it's almost
like a organizational design right so
unlike on some level this is what
companies are and what organizations are
for people who kind of oversee how an
organization is designed but on steroids
because we're talking about lots of lots
of micro organizational pieces fitting
together so it's a very interesting
space I think hi Stephanie she from
Microsoft talent learning and insight
organization so I kind of do the Civic
design but within the context of
Microsoft we look at how we make our key
people process and system enable us in
terms of our culture leadership
principle how to bring it to life at the
behavioral level but my question is
really related to like Steven the work
you're doing right even when we are
working together in the company aftering
it's really hard to find a black time
where people are all available across
different functions so in reality we
have to collaborate and innovate
virtually right so in reality we have to
be more human centric in allowing people
to use a microbe that productivity to
contribute so from your work what are
some key success factors to make those
virtual innovation right as a community
successful what part of it I think has
to do with scoping the work and giving
people opportunities in different ways
to contribute so it's not just you know
uniform way of like contributing but you
can kind of pick tasks and have some
agency and and be able to think about
how your skills apply to the types of
things that need to be done scoping it
down to a task that's reasonable like
the community crit was five activities
that took like five minutes five to ten
minutes to perform and then if you
wanted to you could do more you could
read into it even more and actually the
work you do could be like considered
macro level work and that sense I do
think there's something about that
in-person connection and I realize the
the challenges around getting people
together sometimes but once you do get
them together you can kick-start things
in that setting so we did this with the
conference planning stuff where you know
we had just finished
PC meeting where papers are accepted and
the papers committee was sitting around
tables with their laptops and we said
everyone take out their laptop we're
gonna start identifying affinities
between these papers that we just
accepted because it'll be useful
downstream when we need to like organize
these papers into sessions and so 20
minutes of effort and a room this size
of people you know and we collected all
this data that you know just being in
that moment and being like hey guys we
all contribute at this time we can we
can actually illustrate the the fruits
of this labor right in front of us and
so I think that we've been doing a lot
of things that are kind of hybrid types
of interactions where we're in person
and we're having people take out their
phone show us short URL on the screen
and then we're guiding them through an
activity for whatever the context is one
lesson that I learned from exactly that
experiment was instead of spending all
my time trying to force people to get in
one place fine people are already in
that place and let them do the task so I
just I can't schedule any more meetings
in my life and I can't handle the
disappointment of people not showing up
I'm gonna use who's there it will move
on to the next question I think someone
has the mic there or okay hi I'm safe
savage from West Virginia University and
currently I'm also at Microsoft Bing so
when we're thinking about
micro-volunteering it seems that it is a
10 it is a tangible act it is a tangent
activity that people are doing to their
main work so the mayor for instance he's
gonna be doing his mayor labor his main
job and then on the side he's gonna be
micro volunteering for this community
effort how do you envision that these
interfaces look like is it a website
that the mayor would visit or is it
for instance in maybe he visits that
website when he has five minutes free
time or is it for instance a web plug-in
that he can just start to interact with
to start to contribute thank you I guess
so instructed me the mayor didn't use I
guess they don't I don't think the mayor
necessarily it would be the one doing it
but maybe
in terms of the actual interface I
imagine it's like the everyday
technology that we use all the time you
know websites yes but also email you get
an email and notification that invites
you to participate they're all the same
challenges of like what catches our
attention what things people ignore need
to be accounted for and I think that
there's a certain like with
micro-volunteering in particular there's
a certain fragility to it people coming
in and out you know some being very
committed some others not and how to how
to like build resiliency in the system
knowing that people are gonna like have
you know drop out and and have different
levels of things they want to do but I
kind of imagine it as either they go to
a website and they see that model of
like here's the grand picture of what
we're trying to do and then they've kind
of find their way and into something I
can do or they're already bought into it
and they they get a notification hey we
need you right now yeah I'm open to
ideas I think it's also something that
applies not only at the
micro-volunteering level or at the kind
of like the broader outside inside-out
level but it's also the personal level
so I have five minutes what should I be
doing next given also maybe my emotional
and mental level so what what could I
get accomplished so the next question
yeah maybe I can start replying to that
I don't know if I can hit all the points
but certainly this has been kind of a
long-running thread of discussion in the
crowdsourcing literature right where if
we just break everything down into these
completely not just context-free but
often that pairs with skill free or
minimally skilled work right which goes
back to the Marxist comment right we
turn it into something where you're just
turning the crank but you're turning
whatever the crank equivalent of
whatever the machine can't do today is
right so we've always kind of reduced it
to the minimum amount that we can't
fully automate I think that's the
dystopian version of this but it does go
to the other extreme right so if you're
talking about direct management a lot of
what we're seeing with algorithmic
management and oversight does take this
flavor right you know you have a process
now the question of does that lead
necessarily to incentivizing more work
as a kind of strict objective I could
see it going either way right because
you're saying that in some sense you
make it a more pure economic transaction
right now if I can come in I can do that
effort I can get exactly a payment for
that effort I can reason about it in a
way that I might not be able to if I
just have to show up to the office and I
don't know it's gonna be a good day or a
bad day so maybe it gives a little bit
more transparency in that sense but we
do I think want to get away as much as
possible from using people for any task
that is that mundane and and maybe well
I don't want to overlap terms with the
keynote when I say wrote but I think I
mean in a different context I think
those are also tests that eventually we
might want to automate so but that's a
totally different conversation yeah
where you stop wanting to automate
things there's lots of stuff that
imagine automating that I still get paid
for next question yeah yeah Dan locked
in Carnegie Mellon um I was interested
particularly I was taken in Walters with
the the idea of the chocolate and where
it can break there were suggestions of
where it can break but you don't have to
break it in that way I think there's
something interesting about that
comparing like the way that I don't the
way that like Steven mentioned using you
know inbox as a kind of to-do list or
Lydia saying that you know using
PowerPoint as a way of laying out ideas
almost organizing it and we're on
wondering whether there's a there's an
opportunity for sort of almost micro
tasks as being suggestions for how you
might learn from how other people
structure their own work because you
know you saw the most is like is this
sort of seen 'fl design rather than like
seamless you know you're almost seeing
these are possible breakpoints someone
finds it useful to divide their work in
this way someone else breaks it up in
that way you know they're kind of
different shaped tasks that fit into
different I don't mind sets or different
opportunities I'm wondering like what
would that how does that fit with this
idea of like the third question of how
can we convert complex tasks into series
of micro tasks like is it something that
should be done by people themselves like
so you know some support tool that
almost helps you work out how to divide
up this sort of amorphous blob of stuff
you've got to do into into things I'm
just wondering what that what would that
look like jump in because I think about
this all the time you know I see this
idea of perforation or breakpoints right
as exactly that you're giving a person
the tools that they need to create
either their own workflow or their own
work kind of construction or structure
that's useful for exactly that reason
like you know pick your favorite email
client and to-do list and then compare
with your neighbor write different
things optimized for different workflows
and right now we have these very
opinionated systems right it's there
deal with it if you don't like it use a
different one okay or you have the
kitchen sink and they just kind of throw
every individually optimal thing in a
big pile but yeah I think the closer we
can get to letting people have control
over how when and what their work looks
like is is what's exciting to me well I
want to pick up on this idea that you
can learn while doing micro micro work
which I think it's at this issue of the
work around the work the work around the
micro work you know part of it is that
told task decomposition piece but we've
spent some time thinking about the
scaffolding we can provide right you can
kind of now reimagine what bees like
feedback loops look like you're not
getting the quarterly feedback review
you're getting you know potentially
getting after each task feedback on what
you've done
potentially you know whether it's you
know in a lot of these tasks like you
know the correct answer or you can see
how it aligns with other workers who
have done it when you experimented with
like a human being providing feedback
you know it's something you need to do
and the more the creative work I love
the idea that you can like learn from
how other people are doing the work
somehow harvest that and like
automatically you know offer that as
scaffolding for future workers that's a
really exciting idea
I think agreed with all of us good ideas
guys I especially we're at the idea
about scaffolding and feedback that
feedback is for things that you can't
quite write down or say and so you kinda
have to
I feel like watch somebody go through
the feedback process the scaffolding is
where you can really learn in the
invisible and some I think the
equivalent of scaffolding is the design
pattern and so when I look at creative
problems I don't ever think of how do we
divide those up thing you clearly can't
just draw a line through it like you do
this half of the ad and I'll do that
half of the app that would not work and
so you'll want to look for things that
are more abstract than that so like in
metaphors in this case or the the shapes
there's some principles of a vision that
you can use or or cognition very often
but I actually got this idea from um
having taken a very frustrating music
class that I was forced to take in
college I played the piano kind of like
a monkey since forever I was very good
at it in the read sheet music produced
notes kind of way and I didn't know that
there would be as abstract patterns to
it that there's anyone who played the
guitar knows there
chords chords are the abstract patterns
and the chord progressions make
something sound good or bad and all the
good sounding songs have the same chord
progression I didn't know any of that
and it made me think a lot less of
Mozart and Beethoven knowing that they
had these abstract patterns at their
behest so I do think a lot of creative
things you can find the patterns but
they might be below the surface just
like in music just like shape they get
to more fundamental things that we
perceive like the movement of notes or
the shape of objects I would like to
just add one point and so there's this
influential work from Darren Newton back
in the 70s and so he was looking at the
units of perception and the idea was
that the familiarity with the task kind
of like guides how much you would
perceive the task size to be so for
example if you're looking at someone
doing something and you don't know that
task so novices would describe it in
terms of the exact and unit actions
where someone who's familiar with it
would describe it in more the abstract
concepts because in their mind they
already know what the micro tasks are
that contribute towards that bigger goal
the other point that I wanted to make is
that they're in this journey of micro
tasking we have started from at least in
our research we have started from
prescribe micro tasks so you have these
lists of things or this vocabulary of
micro tasks that you get to use to
define something some bigger abstract
constant concept in in the world
examples that Victor produced we are
looking at more natural kind of
expressions of micro tasks now these
might be broken down into those
fundamental units but if you're familiar
with the task maybe you don't have to
think about those fundamental units okay
so let's move on Michael he has had his
hands up for a long time hi Michael
Bernstein from Stanford may be trying to
stir up a little bit of disagreement
I wonder if micro tasks are the wrong
theory for what's going on here like
that's underneath what you're all you're
all pitching and in that it's not really
about time like making the time micro
it's about the amount of scaffolding
that's being provided I give if you go
with this metaphor as computing as a
cognitive scaffold right that it's a
externalizing my cognition a lot of our
tools are based on this as a guide you
know I think what I'm hearing is sort of
a reaction to an alternative where I'm
giving complete unilateral control over
coming up with the visual blend or over
the the the design for the community
project and the reaction is to say no
actually you know it would be helpful to
scaffold me maybe not through every step
but through a lot of these steps and you
know we have different scaffolds at
different times and when I teach design
we start out with a lot of scaffolding
and you must do this and then must do
that but as you get more experience you
know that scaffolding gets removed so
I'm just wondering about is this really
about microtasks is it really about like
the the short period in which you know
I'm trying to microwave I doubt my
workers it actually about sort of micro
scaffolding about trying to you know
build in more of this kind of
intelligence and patterns that you were
suggesting into the work that I'm doing
like where where do you see this I guess
I get your point
and I do think that there's this notion
of I like the idea that you you take any
task really and micro tasks it for
yourself and break it down into like the
sub steps to help you help you deal with
that bigger task emotionally or with
your productivity or schedule deal with
that bigger task but I'd also do think
it is a bit about time and attention in
the world as it is today that there are
so many things pulling on us that it's
it's like adopting how work is done to
the way that people live now there's a
whole supper question of like maybe we
shouldn't be living like that
moment-to-moment
attention to attention you know and and
we should be like giving ourselves space
to do more meaningful work but I think
it is a little bit about adopting to
where people are what they want to do
how much time they have what's the right
growth at that moment all those factors
you know in some ways like that's a
whole nother chain of research is how
can the Machine you've written a paper
about this how people help predict or
help find work that's the most
meaningful for that person at that
moment so like we can build up these
models of
individuals and help deliver you know
something interesting for people to do
it's like I think we should be moving
people towards more creative work
towards doing that kind of work that we
love and let the machines do the stuff
that can be done in a mundane way so
that's my two cents yeah just to add one
more quick thing I mean I think it's a
kind of a both hand thing
I think the scaffolding that you're
talking about is useful more broadly
than just how we've been talking about
micro tasks or micro productivity but
the idea that two of the key constraints
that have been looked at in this space
are kind of what you're saying often
encountered things time knowledge or
context dependency right and then
thinking about how we can to make it
more modular or have more points of
intervention for that scaffolding so
it's almost the way to think about
fixing the scaffolding in wide range of
tasks so one way that I think about this
is that micro tasking could be a
complement to focused work and that's
why I'm so excited about this and when I
do think of micro tests I'm not only
thinking about doing things on my mobile
in very short amounts of time I mean in
the example that Victor used the fact
that I'm writing a document and I can
just leave these notes for myself where
I need to go and find a reference that
may or may not be a micro test depending
on how in-depth search that will entail
and I think that it's about kind of
being able to identify these task
boundaries where I am able to kind of
create this concept in my mind where
this whole thing contributes towards
something it might be micro it might be
not so micro but at least it doesn't it
it's something that I will have to
switch my attention to and then I can
quickly switch out of next question I
max Paulson from the University of
Nottingham so my question was actually
very similar to your last point and that
is whether or not we are always assuming
that micro tasks are quick and easy to
do or whether we can find hard hi effort
micro tasks to do when we're feeling
energetic
and easy mundane I guess wrote to us to
do one it's like four o'clock and I'm
nearly ready to leave so I'm wondering
whether any of you are considering like
what is the mental effort for each of
these tasks and when should I do them so
I'm gonna start off with this because we
had done some work in the past with
Carrie Kai and Jamie Tevan where we were
looking at how we could use micro tasks
to kind of like build up in difficulty
so we start off with super simple micro
tasks then maybe around the same context
you provide them something a bit more
challenging because they have already
familiarize themselves with the context
using the smaller tasks so they have
already gained more knowledge and
they're able to do those more difficult
tasks quicker so you're kind of like
we're ramping up we also compared this
with doing things I mean so you group
all the easy tasks together and then all
the difficult has together and so we
found that the ramping up provides a bit
more ease in kind of like people getting
things done
also imagine like the chart that Gloria
showed the productivity over the course
of a day how you could imagine you know
thinking about the task structure of the
course of a day you know I like to do my
my email first thing in the morning
some like creative work that takes a
little bit of attention at my peak
points but in the evening like maybe I
can work on some wrote tasks that that
sort of model where it's you know you're
you're either choosing or the system is
delivering you the work based on like
how you feel at that moment individual
differences are important and I believe
Mary surance Keys interns last year
looked at how certain people they work
better in the morning versus others who
work better in the afternoon so you
might need to kind of like time shift
that graph a little to find what each
person's peak point is so maybe I do
more logical stuff in the afternoon
better but yes so there's definitely
also a need for personalization can I
follow up with that on something that I
observed that they were doing and a car
production line and that's that they
were they were interleaving difficulty
of the vehicles that were coming down so
that they could feel on top of the
workload for a bit with easier cars like
low spec mode
they were coming through and then they
would get a hard one which was a high
spec model and they would fall behind a
bit but they could catch up with their
time and so they wanted to keep people
at this kind of 95 percent effort so
they could expand to cover the hard
tasks when it came but then catch up
over time I wonder whether that had a
model that you'd seen because you're
saying whether people should build up
all the easy tasks at once and then the
hard tasks at once I want to leave them
yeah this reminds me of the jury exam
that I took many years ago that had kept
a building on difficulties of the
question suddenly switched to something
like 2+2 and said oh great yeah there is
some work that has looked at how to
strategically interleave either breaks
or break like tasks or these different
tasks sometimes that's good sometimes
that's bad it's a longer discussion of
when that's useful but there's also some
literature a bit less familiar with in
like call centers that looks at
stressful tasks so you think about 9/11
responders like you pick up the phone
you listen somebody have a crisis over
and over you also have to kind of stage
time and sometimes there's little rote
tasks around bookkeeping and things like
that that have to be done and often
those are either emergent or
intentionally put into someone's day so
that they are not just like max stress
all the time other questions yeah hi
Caitlin Hart Microsoft to do I I find
this fascinating I'm also super
interested because the the idea of
taking a big task and breaking it into
component parts is just a core part of
how we develop executive functioning
that's just how our brain develops it's
part of what kids are expected to do as
they become functioning individuals in
the workplace and it's it's something
that I think is really hard in the
environment they grow up in now where
everything is computers and it's
different right there's a lot of
distractions and there are a lot of new
factors that make just managing basic
executive functions hard for kids to
what extent do you think about
the impact on our own cognitive
abilities and what side effects there
might be on what we learn and what we
can do or what young people today would
be able to learn if computers are doing
things like breaking down tasks on their
behalf or to what extent is it like
supporting their development so every
morning I tell my kid come downstairs
and he just comes downstairs in his
pajamas and I said no no I didn't mean
that that means that you had to get out
of bed change your clothes brush your
teeth make the bed and then come
downstairs
so it's essentially so unless I break it
down for him so he doesn't get it but I
think that that's actually a great
question is that and it boils back to
about the bigger picture and the goal so
when you're doing a smaller task having
awareness about what it contributes
towards and how it's helping us progress
in our eventual goal again we are we
don't have the answer yet but I feel I
just feel that this is something super
important that we will have to encode in
whatever products we develop I agree
with that there's a danger you can
measure either the input or the output
and measuring like the hours put in is
the input and we really care about is
the value out and when we just say oh
how many micro tasks
well that really makes sense I'm like a
factory setting where it's really
controlled there's an infinite amount of
do and it's very well prescribed but in
almost anything else particularly the
creative tasks or the writing tasks that
I think about you really want to focus
more on the output and the value that
you're contributing at every step to
then just with the input and so just
like you know shop sees kid it's like
yeah well the value was to be ready to
get out the door not just to literally
be downstairs and that's one of the
reasons why I was saying like when I
just break up tasks and given to people
independently it doesn't work because
the the big picture that the value is
lost but anytime I design a system it's
meant to coordinate people and make sure
the fundamental constraints are out
there like this visual blend has to
communicate football endanger bunch of
micro tasks
then it has to come together and make
sure we hit the right value principle
there so I'm sure distraction is is
terrible for four things but I think
it's if distraction is bad it's because
it tears us away from remembering what
value were really trying to provide here
maybe we're at this moment to where
because we're rethinking how work should
work that we can think about the
different roles right that have to go
around that people with high executive
function people who have that ability to
take a complex task and break it down
could serve this model quite well as
these sort of higher-level thinkers
within the overall overall ecosystem
it's a hard thing to do maybe it's time
to rethink you know how much work we
should be doing you know maybe we're
working too hard and it should be more
about feeling good about doing some
things in a day and fulfilling our lives
in other ways
you know spending more time with our
families or with like civic stuff which
we we just fill our life with work but
maybe we should take a moment ever you
think that right now while we're
rethinking how it works how work works
so we probably have time for one and
maybe two questions hi Sebastian angel
from University of Pennsylvania so
hopefully this is not the last question
cuz it's gonna be a little bit dark yeah
so so far we've discussed micro tasks
primarily to improve productivity but I
wonder if they can also like the
principles of micro tasks can also be
used to for office occasions so for
example I work in a particular project
that my team might not agree with but I
can use the principles of micro tasks to
ensure that no particular team member
can really know what they're working on
I'm like how you know how do we deal
with this how do you deal with an
I mean I think that that is a real
concern I think it's a Jonathan Zittrain
has some examples or you know you have
these little micro cast that seem
innocuous and you build to like helping
some terrible state run activity I think
it is certainly possible to use the
removal of context as a way to hide that
same objective that Lydia keeps trying
to give to people entirely from them
write it that's certainly true now to
write you might not know working on an
assembly line exactly what the final
product is you could imagine a case in
which you hired people and they didn't
know you can imagine hiring a bunch of
up workers today to do relatively macro
tasks that still aren't clear how they
fit together so I think it's that's a
yes it's a concern it's a concern now it
probably will get worse but I don't
really know much about what to do about
that there's kind of a fundamental
information bound I like the analogy of
a jigsaw puzzle so when you have the
piece sure you still have the big
picture and so you want to put in the
piece knowing what the how its
contributing towards a bigger picture
okay so we will move on to the last
question so I'm surprised that nobody
mentioned it so far but what you
described me actually has a name in
industrial organization it's called
Taylor reason it was applied to
working-class people now we're going to
apply to white-collar people before we
rush ahead maybe we should ask the
people manufacturing how well it has
worked for them I mean that the dark
possibilities are endless and I'm
surprised all the way from hiding
context but the idea of surveillance at
the micro test level of outsourcing at
the micro test level the mechanical
thinking of many of these tasks so it
would be useful for people just to look
at the border picture into thinking
about unintended consequences of this
particular path we are just looking in
the rosy Park right now I'm sure that we
will soon move on to the dark side I'm
leaving this to the panelists I'm not
going to even go there
just like Ender's Game
so the whole idea of scientific
management right it was that you wanted
to be able to understand these small
individual component steps right and
then be able to optimize and I think
where you saw the biggest challenges
come out of that was this idea of a
monolithic feature that you're
optimizing for right
it was just productivity there's no
humanity left in the system and I think
that is part of the design constraints
of these systems is that we have to make
sure that we we don't forget that
there's still people in these systems
right and I think that's so I think it's
a useful point in history to reflect
back on then not repeat but we're not I
think doomed to repeat it on that super
positive note I said not doomed yeah so
that I wasn't being sarcastic so I would
like to thank our panelists and thank
you everyone for being here and asking
some great questions thank you